28 märz 2020 in langen leben in
niederösterreich laufen die letzten
vorbereitungen für eine sogenannte medi
weg eine rückholung aus medizinischen
gründen eines österreichischen
bundesheer soldaten der auf kroner
positiv getestete soldat so mit einem
speziell ausgestatteten black hawk des
bundesheeres eingeflogen werden
dazu haben wir diese plattform zur
verfügung mit canon intensiv pflichtige
patienten damit transportieren
sauerstoff anlage an bord defibrillator
per fuß ohren damit ungehindert
transport von intensivpatienten
patienten gewährleistet ist
[Musik]
nach erfolgreicher aufnahme des
patienten in sarajevo landete
hubschrauber wenige stunden später auch
schon ins zentrum ost in wien
stammersdorf die spezielle seine
plattform für hubschrauber er 70 hat der
heute übrigens ihren jungfernflug
und dieser wurde überaus erfolgreich
absolviert bei den patienten handelt es
sich um den bisher einzigen positiv auf
corona getesteten ausland soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheeres
er ist den umständen entsprechend
wohlauf und wird nun in zeitz zentrum
ost behandelt